mardi soir france 2 diffusait le
documentaire noir en france qui donne
donc la parole aux français noirs de
tous âges de tous horizons une émission
envie de témoignages poignants il aura
bousculé l'été au type et a pointé du
doigt les différentes discriminations en
france hier soir sur notre plateau nous
revenons sur ce documentaire en ouvrant
le débat sur le racisme au sein de notre
pays extrait choc dans le documentaire
de france 2 noire en france la france
est elle raciste et si tu es incroyable
si la comédienne firmine richard affirmé
que la montée du racisme est indéniable
en france matthieu delormeau a tenu un
tout autre discours
on sait que tous les gens qui suivent
marine le pen soit raciste ben y en a
beaucoup qui le disent oui mais sont pas
tous racistes
une intervention qui a suscité de
nombreuses rumeurs sur les réseaux
sociaux de leur mot tu ne peux pas dire
que marine le pen n'est pas raciste du
fou de la gueule des gens ou alors tu es
pour le pen alors les électeurs du
rassemblement national ne sont pas tous
racistes comprenez vous le lynchage
contre mathieu delormeau après ces
propos
[Musique]
alors merci j'ai eu 12 lettres avec no
mercy est ce que vous en pensez parce
que vous êtes cette partie du
rassemblement national donc merci et de
la porte parole on peut du rassemblement
national il ya comme un porte parole au
rassemblement national on a six porte
parole parce que année elle vole en 1 21
mais c'est normal en fait c'est
proportionnel aux voix
c'est ça oui non on voit ses ventes et
une voix
vous vous vous dites non moi je n'ai pas
varié en baba d'abord parce que je le
craignais dans la vie oui je sais que
c'est alors je vous dis je ne sais qu il
est tout sauf raciste il est ouvert il
ya pas d ya pas de soucis l'excellent il
est ouvert il a jamais dit que marine le
pen n'était pas raciste il a dit il ya
certains électeurs du front national qui
ne sont pas racistes c'est il a jamais
il alors il a dit c'est pas parce qu'on
vote front national va c'est pas passé
loin d'un front national et moi j'ai un
exemple j'ai ma maman des fois qu'ils me
suis moi on n'en peut plus de votre vie
moi c'est bon ces choix toute ma famille
comme union des missions dans mais selon
ses dires son fils tout à l'heure ça 50e
qu'est ce que la ta maman ya beaucoup de
gens que je croise qui me disent dans
les idées du front toutes les autres
mamans l'amène à misson il ya des gens
qui se reconnaissent dans leur sang
donne parce que marine le pen balancer
ma maman parler d'elle mais parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui se reconnaissent
dans le programme par rapport à ce qu'a
fait avec l'immigration quand elles
disent qu'il faut plus faire venir des
immigrés que c'était extra parce qu'ils
vont prendre le boulot des français et
c'est en train de me perdre avec vos
conneries
j'avais préparé des trucs en plus je
sais ce que je dis je sais ce que je
pense et moi je pense pas que lui soit
raciste et je pense comme mathieu qui a
des électeurs du front national on leur
fait peur alors tourner la tête regardez
juste programme de marine le pen sur les
migrations elle est maligne dans ce café
dans ce café elle est maligne moi je la
cautionne pas je suis fils de marocains
je vais pas vous dire que je cautionne
qu'est ce qu'a fait mais en attendant
voulait nous parler
non mais c'est fou de penser que
matthieu lahaye nous savons oui en fait
ça a été mal interprétés juneau
12,7 depuis de marocains qui votent
marine le pen alors même s'il a rien
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce qui
s'est passé hier matthieu delormeau
c'est vrai que ça a été voilà il a pris
un déferlement sur les réseaux sociaux
il va nous dire ce qu'il en a pensé
mathieu j'aimerais avoir votre avis
puisque vous êtes indécis porte parole
du rassemblement national bon déjà je
trouve que c'est profondément insultant
de dire que les électeurs du fn sont des
racistes et je vais prendre juste un
exemple ça veut dire que là ça veut dire
non maintenant excusez moi c'est ainsi
qu'à la côte quand il ya des racistes
chez nous tout de suite ils sont virés
contrairement à d'autres partis
notamment l' émir où le racisme est
largement cautionner mais ça veut dire
que les centaines de milliers ça des
centaines de milliers ça reste à des
électeurs de nos compatriotes des dom
tom sont des racistes ça veut dire que
les guadeloupéens qui votent marine le
pen sont des racistes ça veut dire que
les mahorais je rappelle que le premier
département du rassemblement national
c'est mayotte ce sont des français
majoritairement de grève l'or noir est
de confession musulmane et ce sont eux
qui plébiscitent notamment aux dernières
élections européennes marine le pen à 40
6 % 46% parce qu'ils ont bien compris
que marine le pen leur garantie c'est
quoi le fait de rester des français en
france mais est de lutter contre
l'immigration parce que être raciste
c'est faire une hiérarchie entre les
gens selon la race selon leur couleur de
peau et ça c'est pas la lutte est contre
la politique d'immigration ça n'a rien à
voir j'avoue comprenait leur charge
contre mathieu donnant votre avis je
reprends je comprends pas le lynchage
sur mathieu parce que je sais que
mathieu n'est pas raciste en revanche il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya une partie de
gens en france qui sont complètement
paumé par tous les partis politiques
pendant trente ans on leur a vendu du
rêve 30 ans le père noël et ils ont voté
à gauche et s'en présentait ils ont voté
à droite on regarde sur comment ils ont
volé à droite à droite ils sont faits
avares il ya des gens complètement
perdus qu'ils on a tout essayé on a
essayé la gauche on essaie la noire
maintenant faut que ça bouge on en a
marre on appâte à fond crèvent de faim
et derrière ça eux ils s'engraissent ils
font n'importe quoi maintenant je vais
essayer marine le pen est ce que c'est
pour autant que ces gens là il travaille
pas avec des étrangers il invite pas des
étrangers ces jeux moi je suis persuadé
car des gens j'ai joué moi je te rejoins
à tout donner des leçons mais je vois tu
aura des gens pour me jeter en version
avec moreno c'est que ici et je le dis à
chaque fois on n'est pas des donneurs de
leçon on peut pas se mettre à la place
des gens ici tout le monde gagne très
bien sa vie tout le monde a dit ça
formidable tout le monde rentre chez soi
et ils ont un logement magnifique juin
mise achètent ce qu'ils veulent et c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas se mettre à la place
des autres moi je ne dirai jamais pour
qui voter et pour qui ne pas voter je
n'ai pas vraiment je vous le dis ça je
déteste les donneurs de leçons chacun
vote en fonction de la vie est là et en
fonction du ressenti qu'il a ça vraiment
je vous le dit mais tu as raison nous on
a la chance de faire des coups on
souhaite pas d'accord avec bien sûr avec
plein de choses et votez pas voter pour
la personne avec qui vous êtes le plus
d'accord mais les donneurs de leçons ça
vraiment chaud on n'en veut plus haut la
charge de mettre des trucs dans notre
cas dit on arrête pas là c'est ça on a
la chance de mettre de l'essence on
regarde pas les cendres regarde pas le
montant on attend que ça fasse clic à
les choses encore une très grande
famille
ça on a la chance nous les privilégiés
mais il ya des gens sans galères et qui
souffre et quand marine le pen dans son
programme c'est ce que je voulais dire
thaler tous qui avait là-dedans c'est
pour faire rêver ses jambes après voilà
quand même chose ou l'avant mais ça fait
messi prévoir pour marcher open c'est
que vous ne votez pas blâmer lui le
programme de marine mémoire de mariage
et les mains tremblent j'ai lu aucune
proposition est ce qu a dit opposition
éclatée de merde alors il dit que les
étrangers qui rend qui rentrent en
france à c't'heure reste régulière elle
va les virer sous-entendu elles vont
connaissent pas elle veut enlever son
destin oui elle veut enlever les aident
à tout au long des 5 et sont 200
français ça fait rêver ça à faire et si
un mec tu rentres chez toi c'est pas
invité il se dit mais la tablette c'est
exactement la même chose c'est
exactement la même chose qui a fui son
pays il a capté le serment vais faire
tourner seront versés moi parler
quelqu'un qui a fui son pays l'ap a fui
son pays pour la pour venir en france
quand il fait -6 moins de 8 degrés il a
fui son pays parce qu'il avait une
misère dans son pays et qu'il est en
galère marine le pen ce qu'elle veut
c'est dès qu'il arrive il dégage moi
c'est pas mes valeurs c'est pas comme
dans la plupart des pays du monde en
fait une priorité nationale où les
concitoyens ou sont prioritaires sur les
aides sociales
les logements beaucoup l'alimentaire
c'est tout beaucoup d'électeurs ils ont
rejoint le front national parce qu'ils
sont paumés parce qu'ils sont faits
alors c'est à dire gueule si on peut
trouver sur mathieu voilà qui émane pas
raciste mais malgrès non mais je rêve
mais c'est pas ça le briquet simard est
à venir hier il a pris beaucoup à
rosario s'est pas beaucoup de trucs
beaucoup de tweets dans la gueule juste
ils permettent pourquoi vous êtes énervé
contre mathieu à ce qu'ils méritent ce
qu'il a pris dans la gueule comme
molière
je reviens
de balsa d'insultés d'injures et j'ai
repris le modèle
a été insulté injurié menacé donc
excuses ne peut pas cautionner cette
déjà à la balance même pu placer une
phrase avant que l'ayatollah l'omc où
je vais vous dire ce que j'ai sur le
coeur lui menace mathieu je suis très en
colère contre vous parce que hier vous
avez tenu un discours de ce que
j'appelle de petits blancs qui sont pas
de son microcosme de privilégiés qui
voit pas la france telle qu'elle est
quand vous dites que les électeurs du
raid ne sont pas tous racistes et moi je
le dis en face de monsieur odoul vous
dites une monumentale bêtise ans les
électeurs du front national monsieur
votre parti est raciste votre quartier
est fondée sur des valeurs 11 millions
française oui millions science c'est
parce que vous les projets suivants 20
millions de français
sont racistes bien la régie de judo
lutte parce que y'en a qui veulent
répondre que tu diras tu dis là le
souhait c'est insupportable en fait je
pense qu'il ya que deux personnes qui
sont pas racistes en france et gilles
verdez et guillaume genton ben
franchement c'est ce procès en raison de
travaux qui nous méprisent et là nous
irons descendants
[Musique]
dont la roue de cyril hanouna qui m'a
traitée tout à l'heure d'ayatollahs de
chez paco chansons et qui pensent comme
moi s'est il alors
excuse moi mais on atteint 40 ans de
retard en fait mais tu diabolisent les
électeurs du front national j'ai revolé
se lanceront à la baule est d'abord le
rassemblement a
tu dis que tu dois trouver ça veut pas
dire que tous les gens qui votent pour
marine le pen ou pour des mourres
d'ailleurs parce qu'il est aussi
d'extrême droite ils sont racistes c'est
insupportable l'idéologie raciste mais
il a bondi au litchi et des gilets
jaunes il a raison les classes
populaires aujourd'hui elles votent pour
marine le pen ont elles votent pas pour
le brier martine aubry ni ni vote pour
marine le pen bien sûr lancé les bonnes
questions c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
racistes parce qu'on les a déconsidéré
non les a pas
l'année 2 étoiles âgées découvrir une
heure
exacte d'arrivée c'est vrai la raison à
ken hildahl il
ya pas d paris dans la bière anne
hidalgo
paris anne hidalgo nominant brasse je
rappelle je l'enverrai le titre de
douchka 1-2-3 jacquet de nice et paris
nous sommes cette fois
c'est sûr ça c'est bon mais
alors si l'émission quand je parle si
bien le dire a dit qu'il est un enfer
non mais vraiment pas que tout le monde
marque et des démagos et disons vous
vous rendez compte que vous insultez 11
millions de français évidemment que dans
le programme de marine le pen il n'est
pas écrit noir sur blanc des propos
racistes pour la bonne et simple raison
que c'est interdit et condamnable en
revanche quand on regarde les propos de
certains mots durs à son lourd nationale
les propos de certains électeurs du
rassemblement national je suis désolé
exercer exemple jouent à ce que j'essaie
de me dire ça j'ai ouvert j'ai tapé ça
voilà janiver le dernier l'arctique qui
tombe antisémitisme racisme islamophobie
des candidats et rennes toujours bas du
fond donc c'est pas des exemples sort
merci dérapages des lecteurs et c'est
donc force est de constater que c'est un
parti qui rassemble beaucoup de gens qui
sont racistes et moi je vais vous dire
des exemples que j'entendrais vraie vie
tous les gens qui disent voilà je vote
marines et bah oui c'est vrai la raison
puisque franchement les arabes rémois et
ses lecteurs la respiration des genres à
6 et une vérité et c'est démago de
déchets l'eau vous insultez des millions
de français oui d'accord oui je suis
d'accord il voit la délurée de finir ils
sont pas tous racistes oui mais c'est un
parti qui rassemble des gens racistes
comme dire la vérité généraux de
qu'est-ce que vous répondez moi je vais
répondre à gilles verdez parce que lui
qui nous accuse de racisme c'est le seul
en fait qui a paré de couleurs il a
traité matthieu delormeau de petits
boulots mais en fait vous êtes des
obsédés de la
sélection c'est à dire que ce courant du
racialisme qui cherchent à catégoriser
les gens en fonction de leur ethnie en
fonction de leur couleur en fonction de
leur religion c'est vous c'est l'extrême
gauche c'est la gauche moi je vois que
trois couleurs en france le bleu le
blanc le rouge un point final voyait
dollars
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adresse au principal intéressé comme
mathieu ce que ça vous a blessé déjà des
arts des impôts je suis pas je suis pas
porte-parole dû ressembler nationale
quand même juste préciser ça j'ai jamais
déjà 6 pourquoi tu dis ça pour rien que
le bien de sa chirurgie je n'ai jamais
marine le pen tu fais comme ça à l'air
de dire j'ai pas dire à nos amis zoller
avec moi hier alors hier il avait été le
porte parole
tous les électeurs de marine le pen ne
sont pas racistes encore une fois je
leur dis tu connais les sept minutes
personnes qui ont voté pour le premier
tour et justice raciste donc dans la
caméra tu peux dire aux 7 pour une
personne que voter que ce sont des
grands raciste ça je te je te laisse la
respecter tes propos ensuite du coup
moins cher garder un petit peu plusieurs
choses effectivement lundi il y avait un
documentaire j'ai vu effectivement qu'à
mayotte elle est arrivée en tête des
élections européennes ce ne sont que des
personnes de couleur qui ont voté à
mayotte à mayotte faudra qu'on
m'explique du coup c'est possible est-ce
qu'ils sont tous racistes et petit 2 du
coup j'ai un petit peu travaillé j'ai
été regardée des sondages sur le parti
ne faut leur assemblée nationale et j'ai
vu ce qu'a vu raymond en effet 60% des
gens qui votent pour le front national
sont d'abord des gens qui sont dégoûtés
de la politique ils ont été reçus des
parties la deuxième chose importante
j'ai lu dans libération de 2010 est dû
ce que voulaient des sources j'ai vu que
34% des gens qui votaient pour le front
national 34 % uniquement à béret à la
politique d'émigration donc arretez de
dire encore n'importe quoi sur marie ne
pas aller sur ce parti encore une fois
que je ne soutiens pas mais tu dis
n'importe quoi gym et les gens qui me
sont tombés dessus mais j'ai halluciné
encore une fois qu'est ce que j'ai dit
jenny tous les gens aiment et qu'ils
votent marine le pen ne sont pas
racistes et lyon me tombe dessus